hello there season two of fortnite
chapter three is here a war between io
and the seven has begun which means
constant map updates are back
the rumbling we felt underfoot ended up
being this a drill the size of a town
filled to the brim with io coming to
take our island it's now time for us to
be part of the resistance we've got a
lot to go through today so sit your butt
down for 10 minutes slapping code
adamaru to help me out and let's go
through all those map changes and story
secrets
it happened after only one season the
egotistical statue of the foundation has
finally been destroyed as the io declare
war on the loopers and the seven his
torso is no more laying in ruins on the
beach and take a look at his head i bet
sloan is happy about this who thinks it
will be rebuilt or maybe one day the
statue will be remade in another's image
over by covert cavern things have
evolved now the imagined order are
aggressively taking over the island a
communication tower has been erected by
the rear entrance and on top new screens
can be seen on these monitors which
could as the season goes on give us
clues about the story of fortnite last
season inside were stone walls but take
a look now they are vault doors whether
that's to withhold blasts from outside
or to quickly bring additional troops to
the island or maybe equipment our new
location is behind here we'll know in
the next 12 weeks either way it's going
to be epic oh you remember those
scanners that i o brought last season
you can find these all over this
location and they are crazy overpowered
you can see chests and enemies it's
ridiculous this io home base is now
unbelievably large and constantly
expanding around the blimp on top is
another ventilation system with more
references to midas's crew from a
chapter ago meowso's bobble head is here
and check out those epic slippers the
zeppelin outside is protected by this
frightening dude who teleports near you
after taking damage he has shields for
days but if you do take him out he'll
give you the hunt master sabres thermal
rifle an exotic version of the one you
can find around the map it's a freaking
thermal scope and it's great oh and if
you like me and you like details check
out the zeppelin the control room here
is incredibly detailed showing the sheer
size and complexity of io's operation
the wall will not be won easily by the
seven and in here there's so many i o
bombs this island may look a bit
different soon
io have gone out of their way to add
checkpoints and outposts all over the
entire island to closely control the
streets it's tough to go 100 meters
without seeing io's influence whether
that's barricades
or sandbags new makeshift i o buildings
and most pois have now been commandeered
and a blimp sits above ominously even
risky reels has been taken io have big
plans here planting their flag and
unloading unreal numbers of items and
equipment they plan to reinforce these
locations constantly which feeds into
potential changes that we'll see this
season i'm sure you've noticed the wall
lines on the map showing the strength
and position of each side blue 47 red is
io as the loopers slowly take control of
more of the red areas these pois will be
claimed so i expect the flags here to
change to indicate who's controlling
them at that point we probably don't
have control over who wins but who would
you pick are you i o or seven remember
at the end of last season when the i o
drill made those sink holes and finally
destroyed a seven outpost in the center
of the island well now they've claimed
that as their own and are constructing
another outpost but this one seems way
bigger than the others a makeshift
harbor is now functional as we speak
another of io's flatbed trucks with more
supplies is approaching they've even
claimed the yellow house forcing my
favorite location into the war not cool
i o oh can we shout out to this forklift
truck who's lifting boulders this
machine is built different
let's start a new segment called weird
easter eggs i don't understand yet this
one was first shown to me by jess on
twitter a new grave site has been added
which is usually fortnite's way of
saluting something that happened to a
player in-game but i don't know what
this one means a half-buried car and two
gravestones and a bunch of flowers if
you know what this is please educate us
in the comments below and i'll pin the
answer if someone figures it out
[Music]
it's possible to follow the trail of
devastation from io's starting point to
find the biggest drill on the island it
looks like it's the same one from the
trailer this place is like a motor home
the level of detail here is like the
blimps yet with a detail that i really
like if you look at the drill bit on the
front it's still steaming and glowing
red from cutting through the ground four
weeks reddened by the heat oh and rest
in peace basketball court and winnebago
that once lived here they've both been
crushed or pushed down the slope this
drill is the place you'll find the most
opposition to your survival a sloan and
a cracked set of troops are ready to do
battle with you and there's always
people in bushes here so be careful when
you have chance take a peek at io's
occupation of tilted towers they've
claimed the whole thing but one building
in particular is very important the no
sweat insurance building their banners
and insignias cover walls and the
windows are being boarded up ready to
defend it inside the diorama is still
here but everything else is filled with
iotech the computers are locked down
right now but one day we will hack them
to understand what's going on i think
the reason they chose this building is
due to its uncanny ability to stay up
under immense pressure this is the
building which withstood a volcano blast
if you're thinking the seven must be
slouches oh no no no take a look on the
south of the island and you'll see a
huge new poi named synapse station a
gorilla outpost for the seven which
already shows us what's going to happen
in the future inside the resistance are
working on a battle bus they are
upgrading adapting altering it to create
a tank of their own we've seen them in
the trailer and they look crazy fun to
drive and well io's tanks are pretty
meaty on the island right now so we're
gonna need these pretty soon one of the
big lore updates last season was the
formation of the joneses a collection of
snapshots of agent jones that declared
their independence from the war between
io and the seven they swore to never
fight again this is now being tested in
game right now as the jones's home is
being upgraded and supported by the
seven this does not mean they will fight
but it does mean they have the
protection of the seven and will likely
be targeted by io the poi right now has
minor defensive upgrades in place to
keep the i o out but for how long oh and
a tiny update the cell underground the
door used to always get in the way when
you tried to go down well it looks like
it annoyed enough people that the devs
have cleaned taking it off its hinges
and just thrown it on the ground quality
of life upgrade they call that i don't
know about you but i was certain the
daily bugle was leaving the fortnight
island yet it's actually still here and
has been claimed by the imagined order
if this is a functioning newspaper
outlet for the island then be prepared
for the i o to dictate what news spreads
around the island another change from
last season sees those five drills which
popped up on the island to spell out
order they've now been converted into
outposts in the good old hot watch style
very modern very chic i like these sadly
though the combos look like they've been
removed as many of their spawn areas are
now completely decimated ruined craters
and broken trees everywhere let's hope
they aren't extinct and i'm going to
finish these episodes with sofa cam
checking on the triple chest spot with
an epic couch in the center this will
one day be important to the story and
until that starts sofa cam is here
so what do you think will happen this
season my guess is that over the course
of the season we'll slowly push back io
towards tilted towers before the final
battle and hopefully an event happens
i'll be back later in the week to break
down the story and law if you're
interested and a quick thank you to
everyone who used my code this week i
really appreciate it here's a bunch of
legends who let me know i'm adam you're
awesome see you next time
[Music]
you